chocolate me now I feel like Leslie
Jones and ghostbusters you want to be
snug when a rock falls on your head
all right mole people try to eat my
brain when I walk and talk within the 49
acres of Grand Central Terminal is
buried a secret train station that
entire train station platform rails and
elevators booked for one customer only
Franklin Delano Roosevelt he's our
president from 1933 to 1945 and it had
polio
a mostly American public had no idea it
was
from the press even arrived in New York
speaking arrived its own private train
and on one of those train cars will be
Franklin Delano Roosevelt sitting in his
limousine he we triggered off that train
car onto the platform will be driven
down that platform directly into that
elevator custom design for the very
narrow width length
wait that was armored clay limousine it
would bring FDR the Secret Service his
limousine directly up up up into the
water for stories that entire platform
this tracks that elevator is still down
there to this day and not only that but
FDR's abandoned train car is still there
what's actively now this is where we
have to turn the cameras off mr.
Skerritt rain black ear underground
underground so underground the subway it
doesn't smell down here claps already so
excited let's step in here that elevator
you will see a mrs. Adlai Stevenson
stepping off senator Adlai Stevenson
remaining on there over here you will
see Franklin Delano Roosevelt's
abandoned train car
[ __ ] / walk-in don't fall down don't
trip don't split your head open I'm so
scared the ashtray
see I get hot here so bad I were an
adult I want to get a a so the that's
like an old-school stretcher yeah
Muriel's
I just love being underground like this
so much push down here so much for your
history I am disappointed by the lack of
all people I was expecting a smell in a
prehistoric art I'm just thinking magic
excelsis
it's pretty awesome we're like in
history when you talk about the history
of this train FDR was here
BuzzFeed was here
you